[Applause]
gunfire in guinea-bissau's capital the
president says armed men attacked the
presidential palace while he was inside
i was in the middle of the council of
ministers with all the members including
the prime minister and we were attacked
with very heavy weaponry for five hours
but now everything is under control when
i was elected president i promised to
fight two things corruption and drug
trafficking and this is also linked to
that
geneva sales become known as a transit
point for cocaine between latin america
and europe it's also no stranger to
political upheaval there have been nine
coups or attempted coups since it gained
independence from portugal in 1974.
guinea-bissau has been a fragile state
for
for decades because of narcotics
trafficking
and the manner in which it infiltrated
state institutions undermined them i
mean the military the police
intelligence political parties
it's not immediately clear who's behind
the failed coup some witnesses describe
the gunmen as members of the military
others as civilians
imbala suggested many members of the
security forces had died
the west african regional block ecowas
and the u.n secretary general condemned
what happened
we are seeing
a terrible multiplication of cause
and our strong appeal is for soldiers to
go back to the barracks
the president had called his cabinet
together ahead of an ecowas meeting on
thursday to discuss a string of
successful military takeovers in the
region over the past 18 months some fear
the violence in basal is part of a wave
of copycat coups
one of the difference between the
situation uh with him and burkina faso
for instance or even mali the coup in
mali
is that he's a former
he's a former general so he he has
obviously
kept strong ties within the armed forces
[Music]
some called embarlo's rise to power
following the 2020 election a coup after
he claimed victory despite opposition
allegations of fraud
they've been reports of tension within
his government and in recent days he'd
reshuffled his cabinet
barlow's described the latest violence
as an attack on democracy and says some
of those involved have been arrested
alexia o'brien al jazeera